en août dernier votre maman est victime
d'une fracture du fémur elle doit être
opérée c'est ça simplement au départ
c'est une fracture du fémur on n'est pas
inquiet non pas du tout voilà elle va
être donc trop spécialisée de manière
tout à fait classique au départ
au départ elle devait être opéré quand
en fait
le parti en
urgence et puis elle devait être opérée
dans la foulée dans la foulée voilà
d'accord et qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
cette opération va être poussé à
plusieurs reprises pourquoi
manque de personnel le blog pas
opérationnel et puis voilà on attend
pour le lendemain et ça me met rien
toujours reporté car manque de personnel
manque de personnel donc il vous disent
on peut pas traiter cette facture du
fémur pour l'instant non
c'est là que tout se joue pour pouvoir
être opéré la patiente doit être à jeun
et selon vous il n'aurait pas nourri
pendant plusieurs jours en attente de
son opération c'est-à-dire qu'il faut
donc pendant plusieurs jours ils disent
on va l'opérer donc il faut mieux pas il
vaut mieux qu'elle mange pas donc faut
qu'elle soit d'accord donc ça a duré
combien de temps cette affaire
puisque jusqu'à son admission en
réanimation le 28 donc elle a pas mangé
pendant combien de jours
le 24 au soir elle m'a appelé pour me
dire quand même donner un petit bouillon
de soupe et c'était le dernier
c'est pas c'est pas qu'elle est morte de
fin non elle était déshydratée
sur la porte il y avait sur la porte de
sa chambre il y avait un panneau à jeun
c'est-à-dire que l'hôpital peut pas dire
si si on la nourrit puisque l'hôpital
recommandait aux gens qui passent
nourrir aux infirmières de ne pas la
nourrir avant l'opération c'est ça qu'il
y avait bien ce panneau vous me le
confirmez deux fois j'y suis allé deux
fois il y avait ce panneau à jeun ça
c'est incroyable vous l'aviez au
téléphone
elle vous disait tous les soirs il
paraît que j'ai faim
tous les soirs vous avez appelé
l'hôpital pour leur dire voilà maman se
plaint à la fin comme on peut faire
pour moi c'était
je pensais pas que c'est vrai quoi c'est
à vous disais j'ai faim vous lui disiez
quoi on avait du mal à la croix tout ça
ils vont de l'avoir pour l'instant ils
attendent l'opération bon après sauf que
le dernier jour j'ai plus cru du tout
parce que la voix n'était plus la même
et puis
vous appelez tous les jours et vous
sentiez que la situation et son cas ça
va vous aviez été la voix oui moi j'y
suis allée deux fois deux fois et alors
vous vous avez vu son état se dégrader
ah oui et puis elle me disait souvent
fait quelque chose j'ai mal j'en peux
plus je veux partir faire quelque chose
j'ai faim j'ai soif
[Applaudissements]
j'étais voir les infirmières oui pour
leur dire voilà pourquoi elle n'est pas
opérer manque de personnel pourquoi vous
ne la nourrissez pas vous ne donnez pas
moi
parce qu'il faut attendre on ne sait
jamais il peut y avoir
un moment où elle peut être opérée voilà
vous n'avez pas essayé d'en parler aux
soignants quand vous êtes allés là-bas
vous êtes pas dit je la sens quand même
très faible maman
aux soignants vous l'aurez pas dit que
vous alliez que vous la sentiez très
faible que vous étiez inquiète son état
ah mais si vous disait quoi j'avais pas
trop de réponses j'avais pas trop de
réponses j'ai déjà eu du mal à voir
cette infirmière là quand je lui ai
demandé
pas de réponse
finalement dans la nuit du 28 au 29 août
le CHU vous prévient que Claudette a été
amené en réanimation pour déshydratation
complète
donc là on vous appelle
on vous dit qu'elles ont réanimation
alors qu'au départ elle était partie à
l'hôpital pour une fracture du fémur
vous avez demandé pourquoi
déshydratation
il y a pas beaucoup de réponses quoi
après nous disent que voilà elle avait
des problèmes de santé tout ça c'est ça
qui a joué et compagnie mais bon je vois
pas
je peux pas le rapport avec l'agent
cassée quoi c'est sûr c'est les
problèmes de santé il faut quand même
lui donner ses traitements j'ai mis
directement qu'elle a tous les jours
qu'elle en avait pas mal si on lui donne
pas le médicament qu'elle avait c'est
sûr ça s'est dégradé beaucoup mais pas
suite à la jambe cassée
alors
elle va décéder
quelques heures après
comment vous apprend ça
nous l'avez du jeu un peu comprendre
voilà vous avez quoi vous avez déjà
convoqué pour nous dire que ça allait
très très compliqué que
qu'elle était vraiment l'un des états
déjà bien avancé
finalement ou pas elle n'a jamais été
opérée
sans lui donner à manger parce que ça
pour des questions
que la nuit ils allaient pas opérer donc
au moins le chef de service de chirurgie
orthopédique et explique que la patiente
a eu des repas après chaque report
d'opération est-ce qu'il a dit
c'est ce qu'il dit alors on a la vidéo
vous avez peut-être pouvoir agir
dit patiente maintenu à jeun donc cette
patiente a effectivement été maintenue à
jeun plusieurs jours successifs mais je
peux vous assurer et cela a été contrôlé
qu'après chaque report successifs des
repas ont été commandés des repas ont
été distribués et c'est fait tenter
tracés dans le dossier alors
le directeur dit ça
plusieurs jours successifs à jeun et
puis là ils disent que les repas étaient
distribuées à qui dans la même phrase
petit déjeuner de midi et le soir c'est
sûr que sur lui-même un bouillon de cube
tous les musiques elle va pas les doigts
non plus
le repas du soir par exemple tu peux pas
le louper puisque même si elle est
opérée tu vois si on l'opère à midi on
doit pouvoir lui donner à manger le soir
ou en fin d'après-midi par exemple
pendant 5 jours puis dire pas distribuer
il dit pas repas prisonnier ou par votre
mère c'est ça le truc c'est qu'on a
l'impression que depuis le début vous
essayez de dire et votre mère essaye de
dire et que personne ne répond ni le
personnel hospitalier ni maintenant la
direction c'est ça qui est incroyable
vous n'avez en fait on a eu l'impression
que votre mère ne pouvait pas leur dire
nourrissez moi c'était le mur du silence
c'est fou nourrissez moi et hydratez-moi
c'est surtout ça hydratation on peut
vivre sans manger pendant quatre jours
mais pas sans moi surtout quand on est
malade oui Mathieu non mais ce que
disent d'autres personnes et c'est
beaucoup plus grave en fait et bête
c'est que le panneau est resté je sais
que l'hôpital est resté ne pas nourrir
sur la porte ou pendant tout le temps
des reports et lorsque les infirmières
passaient elles n'étaient pas forcément
au courant il voyait juste le panneau
elles sont très occupées et peu et peu
nombreuses elles voyaient le panneau
je crois que c'est aussi bête que ça de
ce qu'on m'a expliqué c'est ça le repas
est prévu mais ne l'a jamais eu
une autopsie a été pratiquée
5 septembre
ça fait quand même pas mal de temps vous
avez décidé de porter plainte
j'ai porté plainte le 31 août
le jour de sa mort
pour connaître la vérité et pour aussi
que cela ne se reproduise pas c'est pour
ça qu'on a des témoignages aussi comme
ça parce que
c'est pas possible il faut que ça alerte
et c'est vrai que
personnel hospitalier là-dessus je vous
dis ils sont vraiment sous-effectif et
je vous dis il y en a beaucoup qui me
disent ils en peuvent plus ils sont
surtout là-bas à l'hôpital où elle était
votre maman vraiment c'est catastrophes
d'autres témoignages à Dijon je pense
que les familles sont entrées en contact
avec vous il y a d'autres témoignages
d'autres familles elles sont sous l'eau
qui se en fait du vide de la non prise
en considérant c'est incroyable on a
l'impression que l'hôpital est en train
de de de périr de se fracturer sous nos
yeux qui a plus rien donc c'est ce que
vous espérez maintenant
on espère déjà savoir la vérité parce
que c'est passé et puis voilà comme dit
plus jamais ça quoi ça se reproduise
plus pour quelqu'un d'autre ça c'est
important
malheureusement Claudette
c'est horrible dans cette histoire on
espère au moins que l'enquête du parquet
aboutira ils ont ouvert une enquête et
on espère avoir une réponse
que vous avez quelque chose à ajouter ce
soir
[Applaudissements]
merci pour votre témoignage et merci de
faire connaître cette affaire parce que
c'est vrai qu'on a pas envie que ça se
reproduise et on pense à tous les gens
qui sont actuellement hospitalisés et
voilà il faut aussi qu'il n'hésite pas à
interpeller personnel hospitalier qui
lisent ils ont mal s'ils ont faim s'ils
ont soif parce que c'est vrai que
parfois il y en a plein qui osent pas
aussi la personne âgée qui ose pas
parler et il faut le faire parce que ça
peut être dramatique merci beaucoup